fala galera eu tô aqui para dizer que
esse é a parte 2 de um vídeo tá então
você tem que assistir primeiro a parte
um depois vem para esse aqui a parte um
está no meu canal só queria te informar
esse tá tem a surpresa para você na
descrição do vídeo valeu beleza e
[Música]
e aí galera que assiste meu canal tudo
bom com vocês bom eu vou almoçar
o contorno [ __ ] que pariu chega meu olho
aquele jeito aí mesmo tamanho jaboque
pois é essa música que eu acabei de
entrar é uma música minha que está no
spotify porque até perguntar para você
se você tem nove minutos para escutar
três músicas proteção 9 - não vai tomar
mais solta o som dj hum
e aí
e tem aqui também que pensa aqui também
para fazer a [ __ ] que você gosta né é
a prova essas três música e me dá essa
moral papai é só clicar no primeiro link
na descrição do vídeo de todos os vídeos
do canal é este link que tem para ficar
escuta se divirta a viagem salve a
música me siga la no spotify e logo logo
tem milho aí para vocês mas ok deixemos
de coisa eu estou aqui almoçando lavando
aqui nesta sala que tem um eco de uma
igreja
hum hum hum nas auto cura não era o que
eu precisava fazer a parte 2 que todo
mundo pensou que a parte de dentro
depois que o vídeo era ganhe mas na
verdade ele tinha bateria estava
acabando eu ensinei você e aí o meu deus
eu preciso gravar para o pessoal vai
dizer que que eu tô enrolando que eu não
gravo que tem sei quantos anos que eu
não apareço no youtube que eu tô
desaparecido a polícia federal aqui na
minha casa eu morro de medo da polícia
federal bota na minha casa porque só vão
de madrugada e eu só durmo no que aí a
gente fica apreensivo né porque ela tá
para cá garotada energia que eu tenho
medo de ser assaltado no meio das alta
tá carregando não não dá certo não tava
implorando não louco vai cágado por
favor como eu tô sem tempo e só tenho
agora hora do almoço eu resolvi que vou
gravar almoçando mesmo porque isso aí eu
só vou terminar de almoçar logo porque
quando a gente come a gente sente o
gosto das coisas que a gente tá vendo né
eu não quero sentir hoje de rolo de pois
muito que bem aí
um mousse sei então vamos lá já clicaram
aí no link para deixar uma música
rolando ali por enquanto você vai
assistir já dá o play para ajudar o
whindersson no spotify também então
vamos lá como foi quente parou no último
vídeo a laura tinha acordado lá na van
né na casa do embaixador nós ficamos no
ministério né mas agora a gente vai
saber o que que aconteceu porque eu vou
assistir agora junto com vocês aí ela
sai andando né naquele castelo ali meio
nossa melancólico maquiavélico eu não
tenho palavras para descrever aquele
local e ela fugindo né correndo que é
tic top correndo rufo dá de cara com
quem máximos aí solta a famosa karine o
nosso bem ela olha na parede um quadro
dela nem se ela [ __ ] que pariu meu deus
ele é pintor eu sei que ela passa mal lá
dá um beijo em belo desmaio toda hora
neste filme ela desmaia tá mandando ah
mas você por isso que toda hora vocês
viram acordando do nada lá que tava
acontecendo a maior loucura lá e o que
que aconteceu do nada mas
e é porque tá dormindo você tá dormindo
quem tá dormindo cedo madruga como nessa
aí como ela desmaiou ele pega um negócio
de gelo manda ela chupar bota dentro da
boca dela e chupei aí é estranha né e
fazendo isso não sei por quê porque o
filme inteiro ele tá fazendo outras
coisas estranhas mas quem você pensa que
é para botar um gelo na minha boca hein
ah não aquele bota ela assim a
zarabatana aí a gente homens fica
zangado ele fala com o esporte muito
engraçado porque eu não sei que as
pessoa acha sexy você zangar e passeando
e
e não me tira de fé ele começa a falar a
doença lá que aquele viu ela do sonho
dele sabia que ela é que era ela que não
sei o que lá a história dele por causa
que aconteceu com o pai dele ele disse
que enxergou a mulher bem na hora da
morte do pai dele aí ele pensava que era
só imaginação dele e ficou perseguindo
essa imagem na sua vida inteira viu ela
no aeroporto e pensou pronto vou
sequestrar ela tudo isso por causa do
sonho cara caetano meu amigo eu fosse
comer tudinho as pessoas que eu já
sonhei comendo ratinha visíveis a da
pomba que a rasgada assim do lado da paz
aí na cama de ar para o lado de fora
moço eu tô pronto as pessoas do som
comendo elas teve um sonho que eu não
entendi que era eu correndo atrás de eu
mesmo dizendo assim agora é minha vez
agora é minha vez eu tô desconfiado que
eu tava querendo comer meu cu daquele
dia mas ele sequestrei só correr atrás
de mim mesmo ela disse que ela é doido
não sei que ele empurra ela no sofá de
frente que eu lhe amo [ __ ] ele é
brincalhão assim mesmo a esta mulher q
a deus só pode ser uma piada negócio e
ele fala que não que é verdade ela fala
meu filho mas eu não sou objeto olhou
para ele disse mensagem e ele diz mas eu
sei é por isso que eu vou lhe dar a
chance de você se apaixonar por mim
mesmo você tem 365 dias vai se
apaixonavam eu ver que eu fico
imaginando você só olhando e eu dizendo
que você esteja 325 dias para se
apaixonar por mim o meu deus ela vai
falar que não tem como que ela é uma
pessoa e na minha um objeto as pessoas
vão da falta dela ela tem namorado já
tem família aí eu fiquei que ele fez e
já cuidou de tudo meu amigo moleque já
tem foto do marido dela furando outro
avisou para família que foi se embora
que vai dar um tempo o homem sabe
sequestrar você vê que é a primeira vez
que faz isso ele vai para cima dela e
inédito não faz nada sem a permissão e
diz que não vai fazer nada sem a
permissão dela já com a mão no peito
dela eu testei no meio só se puder mas
se não puder vou fazer a eu sei se
gentil mas se você não for gentil sabe o
negócio é me lembrou o brasil não é um
país democrático né que é de
o fio mas o voto é obrigatório mas se
você não voltar você paga 2 50 e tá tudo
certo o negócio que você não compreende
que você entendeu é este é um aparece
num porão com um rapaz amarrado fala que
ele vai ficar ali para o meu amigo este
homem eu vou te dizer a mulher vai
tentar fugir de novo pega este homem
dando tiro no rapaz aí ela acorda né
porque ela desmaiou na hora do papá
pensou que foi nela um dia acordou o que
é que está lá sentado bonito e elegante
máximo sair ela acorda eles vamos
levantando dar uma fazer as cópias
arrojada viajar daqui lá para tentar lá
mais eu de novo você com esse negócio me
sozinhos você pensa você vai me levar
sem a minha autorização não é assim que
acontece busca empurra ele volta empurra
aqui rapaz o que o homem vira um e a
tarde aí ele fica assim povo meu irmão
essa mulher me bateu foi bruno em cima
dela para enforcar e aí a mão dele você
não sabe se vai lá com ela você vai nos
peito e periquito meu amigo olha eu vou
dizer é problemático viu eu não consigo
entender teve uma cena também que ele
estava brigando puxou a arma para ele
aqui
a cama virou botar na parede aí cortou
com a mão aqui já respeito e rapaz eu
não sei eu não sei dizer se samuel
perigoso em uma arma falar a pessoa quer
transar em ponto e dá uma cotovelada na
outra mas você sair com os gosto de você
sair aí eles vão comprar roupa ela quero
é sair não vai usar esse aí não é o que
é curto ela mais que manda em mim sou eu
e se não mas que tá pagando a eu sai
tomar no cu segurança carrega a sacola e
vai para lá e vai para cá e eu nada de
ver a rola dele ver a [ __ ] irmão que
até agora só tem uma agressão se eu
quiser assistir filme de luta assistir
action ou escuta o meu é p no spotify é
uma luta viu para vocês clicar nesse
link da descrição aí para eu ouvir lá 3
musiquinhas fica aí cara poxa será que
eu vou ter que implorar velho aí beleza
né que é uma cena tem um jantar lá que
ela pediu para ele fazer uma comida
polonesa eu quero ver se tá boa comida
em aí chega lá todo mundo arrumado a
mesma ao do mundo não sentado lá na casa
do [ __ ] outro na na ponta um bota o
prato ela come ele já pergunta se tá bom
ela disse não tiver não precisa
e já jogando um cheiro ou indireta bem
direta né burro querida e aí ele explica
para ela que era exatamente isso que ele
queria dela que ela ensinasse ele a ser
um pouco mais gentil entendeu olha como
ele é legalzinho né poxa ele tem
sentimento massa velho ele ficou
esperando só para ela ensina ele a
pessoa mano ele quer mudar velho velho
[ __ ] e [ __ ] viu aí ela acorda de
novo né quem tá do lado dela máximo
deitado que a barriga parece uma rua de
calçamento bonito rapaz muito bonito não
não é de brother vocês têm que entender
que sempre que eu falo do brother que
ele que tá gostoso faz a bros está
gostoso velho poxa bombom na massa em
isso que eu falo é de amigo é de irmão é
de sentimento tá abrir mão de novo esse
papo de homem bonito velho
e sabe o que isso aí google ou 2020 uma
coisa não quer nada dizer com a outra
meu brother tá bonito e tem que falar
para gostoso próprio eu tenho dó de você
que não pode falar um burro querida meus
amigos faz anos que é isso marcam é como
eu que fala assim outra chupa rola os
amigos windows simplesmente esse rapaz
aí que nunca chupou a rola mas não tem
problema para falar as coisas continua
aí mundo alto todo dia ela está me sabe
que o índio é o cara do momento vamos lá
mas ela decide não trocar levanta vai no
banheiro e tira aqui devagarzinho já dá
para ver um peitinho ai pai para ela
começa a tomar um banho ele acorda ver e
vai tomar um banho também o meu deus do
céu rapaz agora vai rolar famigerada
cena em que eu vejo aula bem é o filme
grande meu filho vai com vem 6 horas
aqui e não chega a hora do novo quero
ele não
o rei vai ele chega né encosta né de
fica todo sexo eu não acho após eu sei
que é para ser sexy não não acho muito
porque eu gosto de cena mas é filme né
tem que ter sendo sabe como é que é isso
aí mas é a cena separado aqui ó e a
mulher olhando diga agora eu vou ver e
eu quase que eu consegui ver a câmera
passou assim eu vi só a chapeleta da
pomba dele para ir na pro assim pela
frente a perna na hora que eu vi eu
disse é napolitana aquelas pessoas que é
de uma cor e a rola de que têm às vezes
parece um terreno assim sabe o arenito
vai mudando a composição de sua base até
sua extremidade aí eu pensei que ia
rolar portaria ele chegou para eles
assim quer pegar nele ai quer pegar ele
meu amigo e meio um homem desse tamanho
do negócio de pega minha pomba que eu
tava elogiando aqui rapaz falando que
você é bonita você que seu avô tem gosto
sorvete aí você me quer meu patrão eles
vão viajar né ele leva ela amarrada esse
filme é só você com segurança levar a
mulher do braço e fica dentro do avião
amarra no centro negócio e ele fica
passando a mão no peito dela não tá
nesse instante livre
o senado no banheiro tomando banho
pelado perdão
e eu me falei um pouco aqui que eu tava
falando do rapaz não é de brother de
amigo para amigo entendeu aí vai amarrar
a mulher dentro da dior para ficar
passando a mão do peito dela aqui vamos
tentar e que a mulher passa na no bico
do peito ficando que eu não sei onde é
que tem esses peito que grita só para lá
para o oriente mesmo então as
mandrágoras do harry potter toque aí meu
amigo parece que ela meio que sacou dele
que que ela vai fazer provocar começa a
provocar onde anda pegando sorvete né
passando na boca lá na água para se
molharem o [ __ ] aí sempre chegou a
hora no quarto né em outra viagem que
eles fizeram que ele amarrou ela levou
para nós ir para lá para casa do [ __ ]
falar essas coisas que ele gosta de
fazer eles dois aí ela vai no quarto
dele à noite ele abra a porta com a
toalhinha bem sucinta eu diria bem
eloquente e ela entra e começa a falar
deles que falar poxa cara nossa uma foto
sua na parede aí você realmente é o
bambam mesmo ele diz assim se aquete aí
ela abra as pernas desses eu não quis
tô assistindo desses agora você vai ver
os seus like napolitana e ele olhando
como que diz assim minha filha vai
cobrir uma casa porque ripa muita minha
aí ele mostra a pomba para ela de novo e
diz assim pegue poço de novo esse
negócio de pega no meu pau não diabo é
isso meu negócio vai de danado negócio
de item de meu papai meu papai meu pai
pega coisa feia rapaz aí ela vai ter paz
aí a porta tá trancada pode a novidade
né sequestrador não esqueceu de para cá
pó e por lá na cama mete logo uma
corrente aqui outra aqui ele disse vai
fazer o que quiser com ela e cada vez
que assim mexe o negócio abre mais e não
vou tá amarrado esse abrir a está
enrolada e deve ter a trabalhar para os
pedreiros na hora de testar aí dá uma
aqui ó aí eu disse que vai mostrar para
ela o que que ela tá perdendo p
na live outra mulher ele se assentou uma
música sexy rolando que era sexy mas
poderia ser essa daqui a mais legal eu
vi ninguém você contando pelo
se você quer matar para essa é uma das
três músicas que estão disponíveis no
meu ip não lê o spotify é só clicar no
primeiro link da descrição do vídeo para
ouvir e drt no meu twitter fixar a
mulher tá amarrada lá e chega outra e
faz um [ __ ] com ele posso trancar se
dedica a mulher se dedica mesmo que eu
parei para prestar atenção e eu não
parece um baygon parabéns muito legal aí
ela vai para a boate o cabra da em cima
dela e ele mata o carvão meu irmão você
não tem nacional [ __ ] aí que eu vou
passar a tela passei no final não olha
só você eu sei que no final estou num
bar que tá todo mundo porque ele matou
um tabu casa dela ou seja tão dizendo
que ela tá atrapalhando ele nos negócios
porque ele tá matando gente não devia
por causa de mulher novidade né a vida
da mulher foi sequestrada e ainda tem a
culpa das coisas aí eu sei que ela
escuta a discussão e vai lá interromper
meu irmão briga a maior [ __ ] ele sai
correndo pelo barco a mulher burro
querida não no mar caiu dentro do mar aí
o
o ônibus na água sábados a laura e
aquele susto maior do mundo meu deus meu
deus meu deus quase que nós perdemos
nossa personagem aí ela acorda né porque
daqui é caiu ali desmaiou de novo mas
ele salvou ela já tava esperando pelo
lado e triste e com raiva é muito cheio
de sentimentos rapaz porque você fica
desaparecendo as pessoas hein rapaz e aí
ela desculpa ela ela tá se sentindo
culpada tá entendendo o que acontece
logo após isso eles trança agora você
até se assusta porque o filme dá um cara
que tá é tão grande que do nada eles
briga e vai alguém morrendo e aí eles
acordem ó ipa e aí eles transa
finalmente você só assiste assim como se
fosse um jogo que eu te respondo
bastante de como é que desmonta no motor
do fusca sabe acender complexo mas você
acha bonito tem uma série que mostra a
pele botando o cuspe rapaz o homem rico
desse que eu tenho lubrificante mais uma
frase que eu vou me arrepender de ter
falado tem uma cena lindas no bar corre
lá fora drone não foi mãe de seu filho
um drone a hora que tá filmando meu
filho daquela cardíaca é isso aí eu não
vou contar o filme todo que se não vai
ter graça para vocês palhaço chegando
vocês quiserem então se você tiver
gostado desse vídeo clique em gostei e
não esquece de comentar aqui embaixo
qual foi a parte mais louca desse filme
mas sei lá maluca que você achou comenta
aqui embaixo que eu quero saber também
porque as palavras deixo com vocês dia
cinco de setembro sabe o documentário
tem um trailer aí no canal de 4 minutos
para você assistir pode conferir é isso
tamo junto não esquece de clicar no link
da descrição um beijo tchau tchau que eu
tô com
eu tô com sono depois do almoço eu vou
dormir
um efeito halo